nicolas tous très bons commentaires de
l'espagne le club du match france en
dehors du temps derniers ce n'est pas là
la mauritanie et les propos d'après
match et de nicolas anelka devant les
journalistes espagnols
le jeune attaquant français maxime bouet
de madrid alors le transfert de nicolas
anelka est celle d'un comité d'éthique
au sporting
ils sont tout à fait l'événement et une
carte dans l'autre il ya deux mois un
homme était trop cher pour l'heure de
vérité pour l'olympique de marseille
championnat 3 1 passes alors une
proposition la zone euro millions de
francs
il ajoute articulture à 300 mais les
négociations capotent l'entourent
intéressant d'avoir été trop gourmand et
puis nos jours
retour à la case départ le club
madrilène a fait très peur durée de 7
ans de son niveau de francs l'ex
attaquant d'arsenal
c'est toujours possible pour deux
raisons premièrement la manne que le
rapport que les droits des musulmans
il ya deux mois juancarlos annuler par
décret on fête les 100 millions d'euros
du club madrilène
pour le président du real anelka est
clair